and 134 days since joe biden promised
not to abandon americans now according
to the washington post even evacuations
have as we told you they would
predictably slowed to a trickle quote
the administration says the process is
now limited by the realities on the
ground in the taliban controlled islamic
emirates of afghanistan now the biden
administration once laughably they
promised they had all the leverage
remember they said we have all the
leverage and the terrorists and the
taliban over them to secure the release
of those on the ground that they
abandoned that was and remains a blatant
lie now one senior state department
official is telling the post that a real
evacuation is no longer possible quote
when you don't have people in the
country there's not really a functioning
airport and arguably there are tens if
not hundreds of thousands who would fall
into the broad category of at risk so
make no mistake this is a serious
ongoing crisis without any obvious
solution completely preventable caused
and perpetrated by joe biden and hope
now has diminished and sadly it appears
that americans military families
thousands of green card holders that are
eligible to live in this country our
afghan allies will not be getting out
for years
if at all
now it is one of the many self-inflicted
responsible for joe biden's plummeting
poll numbers look at this new abc news
survey only 28 percent of the american
people approve of biden's handling of
inflation in the economy a measly 36
percent approve is handling a crime
his overall approval rating now is
underwater by around 10 points in nearly
every single poll the only person
polling worse than joe biden is his
choice for vice president that's kamala
harris in fact no vice president in u.s
history has a lower approval rating than
kamala harris now maybe that's because
the vice president is terrible at her
job for example ever since she was
appointed border czar nine months ago
harris has done nothing to resolve the
crisis she did make one 30-minute trip
near near the border not where she
needed to be in el paso nowhere close to
where the migrant surge was actually
happening and one useless trip of course
you know to the southern border she made
a trip to central america to see the
problems going on there along with a a
whole phone call to the president of
guatemala that's won in nine months
that's it take a look
is vice president hair still in charge
of addressing the root causes of
migration from el salvador honduras and
guatemala she is and i just announced a
commitment that she's announcing this
afternoon why is it that she has not
spoken to the president of guatemala
since june that's six months
well i know that i i did see this kind
of strange report from the president of
guatemala saying that he's had no
contact with the white house which is
inaccurate
he said uh vice president harris he has
not spoken to her and if she's in charge
why why is that
well we have had a range of
conversations peter i think as it
reflected in our readout we put out last
week with our national security advisor
and now yet another massive caravan
another is headed our way kamala harris
has no plan of action no resolution no
future plans to visit the border
absolutely nothing by the way are you
surprised at at this point is anybody
surprised now according to reports
harris often refuses to read briefings
is frequently unprepared for the daily
challenges that she would face as vice
president and get this instead of
actually doing her job the border czar
now spends countless hours berating her
own staff according to numerous reports
allegedly kamala harris is such a menace
that some are openly referring to her
as a soul-destroying bully
ouch now of course amid lashing out at
her own employees kamal also found time
to redecorate her own office with
carefully curated our pieces uh and all
white furniture set brand new light blue
color for the walls and apparently
according to kamala the border crisis
can wait her office was in desperate
need of a makeover mike pence apparently
doesn't share the same decorating tastes
but don't worry harris says the
ridiculous headlines about her conduct
will not be a distraction for her and
tonight one anti-trump columnist peggy
noonan is now imploring kamala to get
serious writing quote the president
isn't all is old and his judgment
questionable she seems out of her depth
we will have another three years of this
sadly the answer is yes sadly i have to
agree hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else